if one of your buddies who makes two
million bucks a year is making fun of
you tell them you're better looking than
they are how do you deal with the
comparison game incredibly easy not one
person's life has anything to do with
mine comparing yourself is just
insecurity right I'm in a very good spot
with my career but I'm surrounded by a
bunch of guys that are crushing it which
is good for me but I'm just like looking
up like I could be there be happy for
them I am good be happy for yourself on
the Journey of trying to get there and
you might not be good enough to get
there and that's okay too you might be a
better dad you might be a better
basketball player you're clearly better
looking than some of those dudes
appreciate it right yeah one of the
things all facets yeah one of your
buddies who makes two million bucks a
year is making fun of you tell them
you're better looking than they are yeah
love it